welcome to the show everybody we have a
bunch of different coveted news to go
over and so many different things glad
you're with us going to be a very very
full week um to start with
we are potentially just minutes hours
maybe a day from full fda approval for
the pfizer covid19 vaccine this is
important not only
from the standpoint of medical but also
because of how this may or may not
impact
anti-vaxx individuals who have been
saying
as soon as there's full approval not
emergency use i will go and get myself
vaccinated and i've expressed skepticism
that all of the people saying that are
actually going to do it
but we'll get to that in a moment
there's a new report from the new york
times which tells us that the fda is
hoping to approve the pfizer bioentech
vaccine that's the two dose regimen
relevant because we're already talking
about a third dose the two dose regimen
of that vaccine full approval expected
today
if there's a delay maybe an additional
day or two so this timeline is on the
one hand it's later than many people had
hoped there's been a lot of why is this
taking as long as it's taking it's also
sooner than some of the least optimistic
timelines which we're looking at you
know later in the fall or at least into
september
i believe that as far as those anti-vax
people who have been saying
once it's fully approved i will go and
get vaccinated i think that for a
significant portion of them it was just
a talking point it was just something
that they came up with to say to make
themselves seem rational to make
themselves appear as though it's not
just unhinged anti-vaxxerism it's
once it's approved i will go and get
vaccinated some of them probably will
but many will just come up with a new
talking point for example if they want
to they'll move the goal posts too well
it's approved but it was a very
political approval and it was rushed and
influenced by the biden administration
so we can't trust the full approval i
would have gone and gotten the vaccine
if it had been a fair and and reliable
approval but it was clearly a rushed
approval no evidence of that but the
reality is some of them are going to
come up with something new now the other
piece of this the other reason this is
important
is that there have been many
organizations schools employers
governments etc that have been thinking
about
do we require vaccination for our
customers for our employees for students
coming back to campus some have already
put in place some of those requirements
but others have hesitated because after
all the vaccine is approved under
emergency use they would feel more
comfortable requiring a vaccine
once it is fully approved by the fda so
that's the other reality the
requirements and the mandates are
likely to increase significantly once
this vaccine is fully approved which
again should be later today or
potentially tomorrow
some people say
they are against mandating a vaccine
that's only approved for emergency use
and so
when we have full approval we're
expecting to also see a number of
additional requirements and mandates and
my guess is
that the people in the anti-vax
contingent who have been saying
the problem now is it's not fully
approved are going to shift to focusing
on what they will say are author
authoritarian and dictatorial vaccine
requirements once it is fully approved
and the expectation is there's going to
be a lot of them there are some
hospitals and universities that are
expected to mandate vaccination once the
full approval hits the pentagon said
earlier this month that they are
planning to make covet vaccines
mandatory for the roughly 1.3 million
active duty troops no later than the
middle of next month but even sooner if
the fda grants that full approval which
we're now expecting any moment uh now i
mentioned that this is approval of a
two-dose regimen you might be saying
well david hold on last week you
mentioned now there's a recommendation
for a third shot at the eight month mark
but the approval is only for two shots
that's exactly right um that is the
biden administration announced you
should at the eight month mark start
getting yourself a third dose
uh the the approval right now that's
been submitted by pfizer which was
submitted months ago is for a two-dose
regimen so the expectation is once this
is approved on the two-dose regimen the
um pfizer will immediately submit to the
fda for expedited approval of that third
booster shot
and then we'll see how long that takes
so the bottom line here is
when we looked at what the reasons why
those who didn't want the vaccine didn't
want the vaccine about a third said
i will get it if and only if it receives
a full fda approval
that's going to happen i suspect
not a full third of those who are
against the vaccine are going to go and
get it once it's approved i think it
will have an impact how big it will be i
don't know now one bit of good news
recently by the way
after a really long period of declines
in daily vaccination in the u.s and then
very slow ascent
we are now back to
three consecutive days with one million
doses per day with roughly about
575 000 people each day being newly
receiving one dose
that's very good news 200 million
americans have now received at least one
dose of the vaccine and in terms of what
would work to better incentivize people
to go and get vaccinated remember that
when uh joe biden encouraged and new
york city announced a hundred bucks if
you go and get yourself vaccinated the
hundred bucks didn't really seem to be
very influential to people and there was
a poll done and the most effective
hypothetical requirement requirement was
if you needed a vaccine to fly
41 of anti-vaxxers said they would go
and get themselves vaccinated that seems
to be a really big deal
uh and then as we're going to talk about
a little bit later on in the program i
suspect
that if you made copays 50
instead of 20 bucks like imagine you
have insurance where your co-payment is
twenty dollars or maybe in the emergency
room maybe in the er you know it's two
hundred dollars three hundred dollars if
you make it fifty percent co-insurance
if you're not vaccinated meaning if
you're not vaccinated and you need to go
to the hospital for covid you pay 50 no
more co-pay i think a ton of these
people would go and get themselves
vaccinated it's not clear anything like
that is on the horizon uh but needless
to say i think it's something that would
very much work
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not exciting like my live streams
and that's why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack monk pack keto nut and
seed bars are sweet and delicious soft
and chewy with a big satisfying crunch
but each bar has just one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and just 150
calories so it's great for someone on a
keto or low carb diet or even if you
just want a tasty sweet snack without
the sugar monk pack keto nut and seed
bars come in great flavors like sea salt
dark chocolate
caramel sea salt or caramel you choose
and peanut butter dark chocolate i
always have a box of these ready to go
in my pantry which is easy when you do
the optional monthly subscription which
also saves you 10 percent if you have a
sweet tooth this is the way to indulge
without the guilt whether it's for
breakfast or in the car or after a
workout go to monkpack.com the link is
under this video and you'll save 20
percent when you use code pacman at
checkout